All right. So again, that's the
likelihood version of Base theorem
To find out the posterior.
We multiply the likelihood.
by the odds
well, if we found out that the likelihood is
19.
19 times in favor of being
detected positive
so we put 19 here.
And we found out that the odds is 1 over 49.
And algebraically if we have this is
also another way we could rewrite this is
19 over 1.
19 over 1
so we can just multiply straight across so 19 times 1
gives us 19.
And then we just get 49 in the denominator.
Evaluate this expression.
That's our posterior odds.
This is still.
likelihood
if you remember we said that if you want to go from odds
to probability
we must also put we have to put
all of our events in the denominator.
So what was 49 again?
Let's pull up the diagram.
Remember this is still about positive tests.
athletes
are not doping they tested positive, but they
are not doping.
19 did 19 are guilty
of topic they tested positive and
they're actually doping. So in order for us to come to turn
this likelihood.
Into probability we must also bring the numerator
which is an event.
into the denominator
So we have 1949 plus 19.
Which gives us 19 plus 19 over
68, which once again evaluates to 28%
Okay, so
This is how this is one angle to
look at the part the Bayesian theorem.
You would first gather your data.
You could also put it into a frequency frequency table
with a modules on the side like we saw earlier.
And then you can plug in the data.
for the events
and you will get
your posterior
probability
and this is the this is this is the
derivation of it.
Now what I want to next talk about specifically why
we multiply
the likelihood with the odds
and that's what's
and that's what we're going to talk about next.